so now let's do a follow-up sort of side
story to the investigation into Donald
Trump as a Russian asset which was our
lead story on today's program and
there's so much new information every
day that it really requires some thought
about kind of how to segment the stories
where does one story end and where does
another begin in this case the second
story begins with how Donald Trump in
furtherance of everything that he's
suspected of doing has been bearing
records of his conversations with
Vladimir Putin and even with Fox News is
not giving straight answers about any of
this stuff over the weekend Saturday
night Trump called in to Fox News no
surprise it was 22 minutes of posturing
about the so-called immigration crisis
and other topics with that whacky
outrageous judge Jeanine Pirro truly one
of the worst on television to her credit
at one point sort of to her credit she
starts talking about the New York Times
article which I just told you about and
says hey Moeller is investigating you as
a Russian asset she didn't use exactly
those words and when I say I only give
her a little bit of credit it's because
she brought it up in bad faith she
brought it up to kind of set it up for
Trump to slam it as fake news and knock
it out of the park she made a caricature
of McCarthyism by saying are you now or
have you ever worked for Russia mr.
president
but even setting it up in this softball
way for Trump to knock it out of the
park Trump still bungles the answer okay
listen to the answer that Donald Trump
gives here listen to the words that he
uses when answering her question I think
New York Times reported that the FBI
opened a counterintelligence
investigation the day after you fired
James Comey and in May of 17 and the
investigation was whether you were
actively working for Russia or
unwittingly so I'm gonna ask you are you
now or have you ever worked for Russia
mr. president I think it's the most
insulting thing I've ever been asked I
think it's the most insulting article
I've ever had written and if you read
the article you see that they found
absolutely nothing this is serious stuff
okay she laughs it off but then you
Trump's answer the article is insulting
and they haven't actually found anything
he goes on to say a whole bunch of other
stuff after that but the answer to her
question is not a denial a simple no
would make more sense if it was true
almost anything would make more sense
than the answer that Donald Trump gave
but he didn't say anything in there
that's a no and then he continues to
attack the New York Times the the
headline of that article is called the
failing New York Times for a reason
they've gotten me wrong for three years
they've actually gotten me wrong for
many years before that but you look at
what's going on you know I fired James
Konya I call him lyin James Comey
because he was a terrible liar and he
did a terrible job as the FBI director
look at what happened with Hillary
Clinton and the emails and the Hillary
Clinton investigation one of the biggest
screw-ups that anybody's ever seen as an
investigation and what happened after I
fired him Andrew McCabe Peter struck his
lover Lisa Paige they did it and you
know they're all gone most of those
people many many people from the top
ranks of the FBI they've all been fired
or they had a leave and they were all
gone this is what they were talking
about and obviously nothing was found
and I can tell you this if you ask the
folks in Russia
I've been tougher on Russia than anybody
else any other probably any other
president period but so the full answer
to are you or have you ever worked as a
Russian asset is it's insulting to
suggest that nothing has been found
Comey was a bad investigator Hillary's
email investigation was bungled Peter
struck was fired and this sort of
amorphous meaningless I'm tough on
Russia none of those are actual denials
and then later in the interview the
topic came up of this Washington Post
report over the weekend which explained
how Trump has been trying to bury
evidence of conversations with Putin
which is a major red flag and Trump just
wrote it off as nothing to be concerned
about which of course is unclear if he
means the conversations with Putin are
nothing to be concerned about or him
hiding evidence of conversations with
Putin is nothing to be concerned about
but this is all extreme red alert stuff
tearing up papers in the Oval Office
notes
from meetings firing the guy who was put
in charge remember of taping together
the ripped up papers in order to remain
in accordance in compliance with the
presidential Records Act every single
one of these actions are outrageous and
there's almost no time to keep up with
them and if anybody does keep up with
them there's certainly no indication at
this point that he is actually going to
face any consequences for this stuff so
this is all getting mixed into this
witch's brew of of nonsense with the
border wall fake crisis with everything
else that is thrown out there not
necessarily deliberately to distract but
it's certainly having that impact every
single one of these stories the New York
Times story the New York magazine story
The Washington Post story every single
one of these would have been a scandal
under the Obama during the Obama
administration and these are sort of
bookends in the constant drip drip drip
of scandal I don't know if we're ever
going to get consequences but I hope we
do send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on twitter at
david pakman show and the big news
continues after the break tulsi gabbard
running for president to see my new top
pick for 2020 we'll discuss that next
today's program was made possible in
part by better help.com slash Pakman
better help is an online service that
gives you access to your own experienced
fully licensed therapist via phone video
and text when you see a therapist in
person in their office it can take three
weeks on average before you're able to
get in for your first appointment but
with better help you're matched with a
therapist who fits your needs within
just 24 hours and you get the same
professional service and the best part
is that better help is less expensive
than seeing a therapist in person as
well plus you will have totally
unlimited access to the therapist you
can talk to them whenever you want on
your phone or computer and because
better help believes in what they do
they also have a full money-back
guarantee if you're not happy with the
service you'll get a full refund no
questions asked all of their therapists
go through an
densive vetting process and are required
to have at least three years of
experience before joining better help so
you know you're getting someone who's
fully qualified to help you but if you
don't think that your therapist is a
good fit better help lets you switch to
someone new at any time if you've been
thinking about getting involved with
therapy you should really check out
better help just click the link
underneath this video